sur public sénat
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur public
sénat ce matin je vous propose de voir
une table ronde consacrée à l'avenir de
la zone euro et au rôle de la banque
centrale européenne hier dans un rapport
jean arthuis ancien ministre des
finances et actuel sénateur centriste de
la mayenne plaidé pour une nouvelle
gouvernance économique de la zone euro
avec la création d'un trésor européen
mais aussi la fusion des fonctions de
président du conseil européen les
président de la commission européenne
alors sans plus tarder cette table ronde
bonne matinée à tous mesdames et
messieurs chers collègues
si vous le voulez bien nous pourrions
entamé cette table ronde et dont je
rappelle l'intitulé à venir de la zone
euro vers un rôle plus actif de la
banque centrale européenne et dans la
fiche que j'ai sous les yeux on n'a même
pas mis de points d'interrogation voilà
donc cette cette audition est une
audition doublement commune puisqu'elle
est organisée d'une part par la
commission des finances et d'autre part
par la délégation à la prospective dont
le président à notre collègue membre de
la commission des finances joël bourdin
et et les communes aussi parce que nous
avons trois et trois économistes
en face de nous patrick artus professeur
associé à rien directeur de la recherche
et des études économiques de natixis
pierre jaillet directeur général des
études et des relations internationales
de la banque de france et gilles moec
chef économiste à la deutsche bank
alors l'un de vous me disais bien
ce temps quand il y a deux économies 6 à
3 aux pignons donc vont nous nous nous
allons nous efforcer de vous faire
réagir
espérant des convergences sur les
questions que nous aurons à poser je
rappelle que patrick artus a déjà été
auditionné par la commission des
finances en séance plénière mais c'était
le 17 juin 2003 c'est à dire il ya un
monde
et quant à nos deux autres invités nous
n'avons pas eu jusqu'à présent le
plaisir de les auditions alors un mot
très bref d'introduction si vous le
permettez
chacun sait que la crise de la zone euro
est une crise de confiance que les
titres de dette souveraine ne sont plus
systématiquement considérés comme sûrs
ce qui peut enclencher ces fameuses
anticipation auto réalisatrice qui sont
au coeur de l'analyse des marchés la
question du rôle de la banque centrale
européenne est donc double quel doit
être son rôle institutionnel
si l'on souhaite
et comment ne pas la souhaiter la
pérennité de la zone euro quel rôle doit
elle jouer à court terme pour permettre
à nos états de sortir de la phase aiguë
de crise dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons peut-être encore et beaucoup
deux choses ont naturellement été dites
écrites et sur ces sujets et je pense au
titre que patrick artus avait retenu
pour un petit ouvrage dont je recommande
souvent la lecture c'était les
incendiaires
n'est ce pas et cette appellation
s'appliquer aux banques centrales aux
différentes banques centrales
nous étions dans la période d'avant la
crise et ils s'inquiétaient de ce que
les banques centrales n'est pas selon
lui prêtait une attention suffisante aux
bulles à l'envolée de certaines valeurs
d'actifs sur leur territoire alors
certains considèrent que la banque
centrale européenne devrait jouer d'une
manière ou d'une autre directement ou
indirectement un rôle de prêteur en
dernier ressort et d'autres où les mêmes
ont pu envisager de transformer le fonds
européen de stabilité financière en
banque pour qu'il puisse se refinancer
auprès de la banque centrale européenne
en utilisant les titres des états comme
collatéral et cette proposition la
commission des finances j'allais dire
l'ancien l'avait reprise mais je ne suis
pas si sûr que ça que que fabre
rapporteur général nous dira si si si il
y à une remise en cause majeure danser
dans ses analyses et cette proposition
nous l'avions fait notre dans un rapport
de début septembre et au demeurant et
elle est devenue la position du
gouvernement français dans ses
négociations avec nos partenaires et
même mais je ne suis pas le meilleur
exégètes à ce sujet et si je me trompe
elle a été également adoptée ne par le
candidat socialiste à l'élection
présidentielle savant vous nous le vous
nous le dire et vous nous direz qu elle
est là juste là juste exégèse le cas
échéant jouer simplement souligné que
dans le mouvement des idées et
il peut y avoir des td t td des
préoccupations assez largement commune
mais comme nous savons ce projet se
heurte à l'opposition de la banque
centrale européenne elle-même et de
l'allemagne ce qui doit nous conduire à
nous demander s'il est possible de
sortir de la crise sans que la banque
centrale joue un tel rôle direct ou
indirect de prêteur en dernier ressort
alors peut-elle encore améliorer ses
modalités d'intervention dans le cadre
institutionnel qui est aujourd'hui le
sien dans les pratiques qui sont les
siennes
est ce une question purement technique
est c'est une question beaucoup plus
large concernant l'édifice
institutionnel lui-même de l'union
européenne et de la zone euro et enfin
et enfin du point de vue de la politique
économique
pouvons nous considérer les uns et les
autres que la discipline budgétaire sera
une condition suffisante conditions
nécessaires sans doute mais sera t-elle
une condition suffisante pour ramener la
confiance du monde dans la zone euro à
titre d'introduction
je me bornerai à ce propos et je
m'empresse de passer la parole à joël
bourdin et madame briques nicole bricq
rapporteure générale
et nous livrera peut-être son approche
liminaire et puis nous le passeront à
l'audition à proprement parler et et en
demandant chacun d'aider des
intervenants de se borner à une première
prise de parole à ces brèves 10 minutes
si vous voulez bien respecté cette règle
du jeu avec dans l'ordre pierre jaillet
et notamment pour nous rappeler ce que
la banque centrale européenne a fait
depuis le début de la crise ce qu'elle
pourrait de son point de vue faire de
plus et puis peut-être nous dira aussi
puisqu'on est au sein du système
européen des banques centrales ce que
vous les banquiers centraux attendait
des états vous êtes indépendant vous
avez capacité de vous exprimer sur ce
type des choses naturellement et en
langage banque centrale
j'ai entendu la foule ensuite gilles
moec chef économiste à la deutsche bank
qui pourrait nous présenter sa
conception du rôle de la banque centrale
européenne dans la sortie de crise et
patrick artus qui réagira sans doute
avec la liberté qui est la sienne 1 qui
s'est toujours prendre son public à
contre pied pour ne pas lasser
la tension d d d auditeurs mais je pense
plus particulièrement aux analyses qu'il
a récemment publié sur l'éventualité du
recours par les états à la répression
financière nous dira ce qu'il faut
entendre par là ou sur les questions de
collatéralisation de leurs dettes voilà
j'en ai donc terminée de cette
présentation et je prie joël jourdain de
bien vouloir tant à paroles merci
monsieur le président madame la
rapporteure générale
chers collègues mesdames messieurs sur
le graphe sujet qui nous réunit je suis
ravi de voir associer la délégation à la
prospective que je préside la commission
des finances dont je m'honore
effectivement de faire partie et comme
comme vous je suis ravi d'accueillir
nous nos experts que nous connaissons
bien nous attendons beaucoup de vous
messieurs pour déchirer ce brouillard
opaque qui encombrent notre horizon et
et pour disons nous donner des
perspectives d'avenir en matière de le
gestion de l'euro et et de gestion de la
banque centrale dans la crise actuelle
les regards convergent vers la banque
centrale européenne bien évidemment est
elle vraiment l'unique objet de notre
sentiment je n'en sais rien mais nous
attendons de vous des réponses à ce
sujet pour certains des analystes de
l'économie notre bce est un organe
défaillant prisonnier de son ciblage sur
l'inflation qui en fait un contrôleur
des prix et rien de plus pour d'autres
elle aurait un autre tort le tort
d'intervenir
ces récents dans l'achat de titres
publics en quelque sorte elle en ferait
trop ou pas assez
c'est dire qu'elle reste méconnu et que
doivent être mieux affirmer ses
compétences doit elle se contenter de
redécouvrir ce que dans un passé récent
on appelait le consensus de washington
qui n'a pas franchement abouti à des
résultats
exaltant ou doit-on la faire évoluer
vers un système de banque centrale
élargi complété par un objectif de
stabilité financière de contrôle des
émissions de crédits et de surveillance
du prix des actifs
en clair
peut-on contrôler les prix ce qui est
l'objectif qui est fixé pour la bce sans
se soucier d'évolution de tous les
compartiments de la masse monétaire
voilà monsieur le président j'ai été
bref
merci beaucoup cher collègue madame le
rapporteur général
moi je poserai mes questions si elles
n'ont pas été traitées ou pas assez
après les interventions de nos invités
mais je voudrais leur faire part très
rapidement et leur demander leurs
appréciations peut-être qu'ils le font
dans leur exposé de deux observations il
semble qu'au sein de la zone euro
finalement compte tenu de la crise
et bien il ya deux appréciations
la première qui est plutôt celle
de l'allemagne et de la de la banque
centrale européenne qui considère que la
discipline budgétaire est un préalable à
toute autre mesure
et puis d'un autre côté la conception du
fmi qui est du reste quand on regarde
les appréciations des agences de
notation on retrouve une certaine
coïncidence entre ces appréciations et
ce que dit le fmi qui met il met
l'accent sur la nécessité de ne pas tuer
la croissance par trop d'austérité et
j'ai même vu que le fmi recommandé à
l'espagne de ne pas respecter la
trajectoire trajectoire budgétaire pour
ne pas mettre en péril sa croissance
donc les deux points de vue semblent au
moment où nous parlons inconciliables
qu'en pensez vous et puis la deuxième
observation elle tient à l'origine de la
crise elle est plutôt considéré par les
économistes
à l'origine des déséquilibres qui des
balances des paiements qui sont apparues
après l'introduction de la monnaie
unique et des écarts de compétitivité
qui en ont résulté
alors dans ces conditions c'est une
question le remède actuelle qui est
préconisé qui consiste à soigner la zone
euro par la rigueur budgétaire est il
approprié
si les causes profondes sont là voilà et
bien messieurs les économistes vous
allez pouvoir vous allez pouvoir traiter
de ces de ces sujets
en d'autres termes avant nous des
chances raisonnables de mourir guéri
enfin c'est une heure sont un peu
triviale et peut être présentés
préoccupations qui peuvent être dans les
têtes et je ne plaisante pas davantage
je passe la parole à monsieur pierre
jaillet
messieurs les présidents adam le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs bonjour et merci pour votre
accueil
je tiendrai je pense monsieur le
président dans la dans la marge de 10
minutes que vous m'avez à louer c'est un
sujet effectivement qui est qui et chaud
qui est évolutif et sur lequel on a
besoin sans doute de clarification un
petit mot d'abord sur la crise de la
dette souveraine dont on dit que c'est
la troisième phase de la crise globale à
la con a eu la crise bancaire et
financière ensuite on a eu la crise
économique est réelle et d'une certaine
manière la crise de la dette souveraine
c'est un petit peu l'addition de ces
deux premières crises ça coûte cher ça
sera long à payer et c'est la raison
pour laquelle si c'est douloureux et
c'est la raison aussi pour laquelle les
banques centrales ont un rôle
particulièrement à jouer là dessus en
liaison bien sûr avec des autorités
budgétaires un mot quand même lorsqu'on
regarde la façon dont les marchés
apprécient le risque souverain dans la
zone euro on se demande parfois si les
primes de risque sur certains pays de la
zone euro ne sont pas un petit peu en
décalage par rapport aux fondamentaux
regardons par exemple le fait que
l'italie ne dégage pratiquement à un d
un surplus primaire à l'heure actuelle
alors que ce n'est pas le cas pour
d'autres pays comme le royaume-uni les
etats-unis
lorsqu'on regarde les dettes publiques
elles sont beaucoup plus importants dans
les pays où je viens de citer
et même au japon que dans la zone euro
240 % pour le japon 90 % pour la zone
euro etc
non je pense qu'il ya un certain travail
de relativisation affaire ensuite
pourquoi la zone euro a été
sanctionné je pense à deux égards
d'abord parce qu'effectivement un
certain nombre de fondamentaux qui
étaient apparus comme bon avant la crise
sont apparus beaucoup moins bon on a
commencéà plus regardées notamment les
déséquilibres extérieurs de la zone euro
alors quand c'était davantage ou trop
focalisé sur l'équilibré des finances
publiques
et puis il ya sans doute aussi le fait
que l'ensemble des pays de la zone
sanctionner aussi sont sanctionnés aussi
par les faiblesses je dirais de jeunesse
de la zone euro et c'est la raison pour
laquelle les réformes qui ont été
annoncées par les chefs d'état et du
gouvernement les des trois piliers
renforcement de la discipline budgétaire
renforcement les meilleurs pertinence de
la surveillance est mise en place de
deux mécanismes de solidarité comme le
fonds européen de stabilité financière
et puis à partir de 2012 le mécanisme
européen de stabilité sont bienvenues
alors sur qui pour ce qui concerne plus
spécialement la politique de
l'eurosystème et la bce vous avez enlevé
le point d'interrogation j'aurais
presque tendance à leur maître monsieur
le président vers vous me surprenez pas
monsieur le directeur général je vous
provoque est alors je vais quand même
rester ouvert et ne pas trop utiliser la
langue de bois et mais il ya trois
aspects il ya les mesures
conventionnelles
il ya les mesures dites non
conventionnelles et puis elle mesure qui
est pas spécifiquement de la politique
monétaire qui est le programme d'achat
de titres publics son appel de smp
securities markets programme sur les
mesures non conventionnelles
je crois que ce qu'il faut noter c'est
la forte réactivité de l'ensemble des
banques centrales y compris de la bce
l'eurosystème
entre octobre 2008 et juin 2009 c'est à
dire la période post lehman les taux le
taux directeur a été abaissé de 3 125
points de base il est passé de 4,25 à 1
et d'autre part les
des conditions monétaires sont devenus
extrêmement accommodante lorsqu'on
regarde par exemple des taux réels qui
ont été négatifs pratiquement sûr depuis
l'ensemble de la période
ils sont encore toujours négatif
d'ailleurs si vous prenez le taux
directeur actuellement de l'ordre de 1,7
et 2 % les conditions monétaires et
financières globales qui réunissent à la
fois les conditions monétaires les
conditions financières au sens des taux
à long terme et bien sûr le taux de
change effectif réel sont sont souples
quand vous prenez syndicats tirent des
indicatifs des indicateurs pardon de
type taux de taylor qui essaie de
rapprocher les conditions monétaires de
conditions réelles telles que l'écart
par rapport à les cars de production ou
par rapport à la cible d'inflation on
est aussi dans des zones qui restent
très très accommodante
donc du point de vue des mesures non
conventionnelles
la difficulté qu'ont rencontrées en
réalité toutes les zones monétaires
c'est qu'on a approché la zone dite du
taux zéro en dessous duquel on ne peut
pas blessé par définition et dans ce cas
là effectivement on est amené à arbitrer
sur des mesures qui ne sont plus des
mesures non conventionnelles c'est à
dire le maniement des taux directeurs
mais on est obligé d'avoir accès à
d'autres types de mesures qu'on appelle
mesures non conventionnelles ou
quantitative et ce sera mon deuxième
point alors sur les mener sur les
mesures non quantitative je crois qu'il
faut quand même
battre un certain nombre de lieux
communs en gros l'idée c'est de dire il
ya fort activisme du côté dames en
angleterre du fait de la banque du japon
et il ya une espèce d'immobilisme du
côté l'eurosystème et de la banque
centrale européenne je pense que c'est
pas c'est pas tout à fait vrai et
d'ailleurs un premier indicateur c'est
de regarder l'ensemble des actifs de ces
banques centrales par rapport à un
indicateur indiscutable qui est le pin
nominal et lorsque vous regardez le
bilan d'euros système par rapport au pin
nominale de la zone euro ces 26 %
comparé à 18% pour le fed à 19% pour la
banque d'angleterre 30% pour le japon
mais le japon avait une longueur
d'avancé je dirais même beaucoup de
longueurs d'avancé puisqu'il a commencé
en fait sa politique de mesures non
conventionnelles dix ou quinze ans
auparavant
donc je crois que ce qui différencie
plus ce ces deux banques centrales de
l'eurosystème versus le reste du monde
c'est moins la masse critique
d'intervention que des modalités
d'intervention je pense que les
frappaient le quantitative easing leu
leu leu des politiques d'assouplissement
d'assouplissement quantitatif
en fait c'est très spécifique dans les
dents dans les différentes zones
aux etats unis c'est essentiellement des
achats sur les marchés pourquoi parce
que les états unis en particulier suis
lancé essentielle ment sur le marché à
trois quarts pratiquement des
financements décalé mais américaine dans
le cas de la zone euro ça se passe
essentiellement par le financement un
terme il y ait des banques et c'est la
raison pour lequel de quantitative
easing d'une certaine manière
pratiquement passe par leur financement
qui est devenu massif du système
bancaire de la zone euro et donc au delà
de l'arsenal des mesures non
conventionnelles qui ont été mobilisés
depuis la période post les médias
l'élargissement des garanties acceptées
dans le cadre de la politique monétaire
l'allongement à trois mois et puis à 6
mois et puis il ya un an puis toutes ces
mesures sont qu'on peut considérer comme
non conventionnelles à s'entasser gars
ont porté ont porté leurs fruits ont été
relativement efficace alors il ya eu un
pas supplémentaire en décembre dernier
avec ce qu'on appelle la facilité à très
long terme puisqu'il s'est agi
de d'allouer au secteur bancaire de la
zone euro 300d des liquidités à 36 mois
se dire à 3 ans et de façon illimitée et
à taux fixe et les banques
comme vous l'avez vu on est extrêmement
intéressés par cette facilité puisque
nous avons loué 489 milliards ce qui
évidemment a eu des effets sur lequel je
reviendrai tout à l'heure quels qu'en
soient les effets de cette dernière
mesure
si on regarde l'efficacité combiner
l'ensemble de ces mesures
je pense que d'une certaine manière une
chose qui est importante pour les
autorités monétaires européennes c'est
que leur mandat d'abord été respectée
les anticipations d'inflation sont
restées stables aux alentours de 2 même
si le indice des prix lui-même a évolué
voix largement au dessus d'eux ce qu'ils
montrent d'ailleurs qu' un certain
pragmatisme dans la gestion de cette
cible d'inflation
il n'y a pas de credit crunch au sens de
ré rétrécissement des conditions d'accès
au crédit qui mettrait à mal la reprise
puisque actuellement en france par
exemple les crédits aux entreprises
progressent de l'ordre de 4 et demi pour
cent les crédits aux ménages de l'ordre
de 6% pour la zone euro on a des taux un
petit peu moins élevé un ennemi et 2
respectivement les marchés de la dette
et corporate des entreprises tend à se
ré ouvrir et à se formaliser il ya eu
aussi une normalisation des conditions
du fonctionnement du marché
interbancaire ce qui est évidemment très
important et on le voit par la baisse du
prime entre les taux risque et d'énormes
risques et qui revient à des niveaux qui
ne sont pas tout à fait normaux mais qui
sont beaucoup moins important que ce
qu'on avait connu dans la période disons
2008-2009 et même 2010 est donc tout
cela est évidemment d'en bas dans le bon
sens alors ensuite sept
mesure de 36 mois a eu un effet
particulier qu'elle a sans doute et mes
amis et collègues ici peut-être le
confirmeront changer un petit peu la
physionomie et l'ambiance des marchés
qui étaient très dramatisante jusqu'à
novembre qu'il est beaucoup moins
maintenant pourquoi parce que cette
mesure a permis une certaine manière de
sécuriser le financement le
refinancement des banques à horizon de
trois ans ce qui évidemment a par effet
de contagion sympathique je dirais a
permis de rassurer un petit peu
l'ensemble des marchés sur la capacité
d'éviter une crise grave de liquidités à
cet horizon alors maintenant et ça sera
mon dernier point le programme et c'est
le troisième étage de certaines mesures
des mesures non conventionnelles c'est
le 6 et 2 programme smp le programme
d'achat alors ce programme a été lancé
en 2010 relancer si je peux dire à l'été
2011 suite à l'aggravation de la crise
souveraine et selon dés avec des
objectifs qui étaient très claires
premier objectif c'est faire en sorte
que les mécanismes de transmission de la
politique monétaire unique soit rétabli
parce qu'ils avaient été disons
détériorer détériorer parce que
précisément les primes de risques j'ai
évoqué au début de mon intervention
était allé dans des sens qui était
complètement décalé par rapport aux
fondamentaux d'une certaine manière
remettait en cause de l'unicité de la
politique monétaire unique et d'autre
part a évidemment réduire les
turbulences ramener une certaine
stabilité sur des marchés qui étaient
très très désorienté alors faut-il aller
plus loin et là la question
effectivement se pose de la question du
prêteur en dernier ressort je trouve que
cette notion est souvent introduit
souvent beaucoup de confusion que le la
bce l'eurosystème comme toutes les
banques centrales jouent un rôle de
prêteur en dernier ressort ce n'est
absolument pas en question mais je pense
que la mesure précisément j'ai dit et
indiqué tout à l'heure
notamment le fait d'allouer 500
milliards pratiquement à trois ans de
façon illimitée avec une très large
gamme de collatéral c'est bien d'une
certaine manière une mesure de prêteur
en dernier ressort puisque c'est se
substituer un marché qui ne joue plus
son rôle
est ce qu'il faut aller plus loin est ce
que l'eurosystème et a le mandat pour
être prêteur en dernier ressort sur les
dettes publiques
c'est un exercice complètement différent
parce que l'or dans ce cas-là ça voulait
dire que l'on substitue prêteur en
dernier ressort un assureur en dernier
ressort
l'assureur en dernier ressort des dettes
publiques c'est le contribuable ça doit
pas être les banques centrales et je
remarque aussi que lorsque l'on regarde
ce qui s'est passé ou ce qui se passe en
angleterre au royaume-uni aux etats-unis
au japon
les banques centrales ne finance pas ou
plutôt le programme quantitatif n'a pas
pour objectif de financer des états il a
pour objectif de faciliter des
conditions de financement sur les
marchés est d'ailleurs ces états ne sont
absolument pas la recherche de prêteur
en dernier ressort
merci dieu merci parce qu'ils sont tout
à fait capables et ils ont d'ailleurs un
accès tout à fait facilité aux marchés
confère des primes de risque qui reste
tout à fait raisonnable voire très basse
dans le cadre dans le cas des états unis
et du royaume uni
en conclusion effectivement vous avez
dit monsieur le président que c'est
intéressant aussi d'avoir une idée de ce
qu'est ce que les banques centrales
attendent du côté des états j'ai évoqué
tout à l'heure le programme de réformes
qui tout a bien tout à fait bienvenu
pour réparer les erreurs de jeunesse
certains diraient ces deux erreurs peut
être plus grave
moi je pense des erreurs de jeunesse de
la zone euro à la fois sur les trois
piliers la discipline bugétaire de la
pertinence de la surveillance
macroéconomique et des mécanismes de
solidarité et d'une certaine manière on
voit bien que on peut voir ses skis
c'est une espèce de partage des rôles
assez clair entre d'une part les états
qui doivent reconstituer des marges de
manoeuvre budgétaires et maintenir
l'ordre est sur une trajectoire
soutenable les mécanismes de solidarité
européen qui sont destinés à faire des
mécaniques à altair des programmes
d'ajustement conditionnelle c'est à dire
à faire en sorte de venir au secours des
états qui le méritent parce que ils
auront fait en sorte de rester dans 10
ans 10 d'une situation de solvabilité
correct et puis l'eurosystème et
la bce qui au delà de son rôle de
politique monétaire qui continuera aura
toujours via le smp ou d'autres moyens
tout à fait les possibilités de
continuer à faire en sorte que les
marchés fonctionnent le mieux possible
je vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur le directeur
général je me tourne donc vers monsieur
gilles moec pour qu'il vous présente son
analyse réagissent le cas échéant aux
propos qui ont été
tenue des j'aurais tendance à lui
demander si le groupe de la deutsche
bank a fait usage et dans quelle dans
quel esprit de la facilité illimitée qui
vient d'être révoqué par votre
prédécesseur sur les présidents même le
rapporteur je vais mais les sénateurs
merci d'abord de me donner l'occasion de
de réaliser un rêve puisque parler
totalement librement de politique
monétaire après avoir passé douze ans à
la banque de france qui était mon cas
avant de rejoindre le secteur privé et
ça je le redis on ressent comme une
véritable libération
donc nous merci vraiment de me donner
cette occasion là à bébé mais mais mais
tu verras pierre que je m'éloignais
c'est peu finalement de ce que j'ai
appris à croix des petits champs pour
être plus sérieux en réponse à trois
questions directes le paysan directeur
général de deutsche bank s'exprimer
là-dessus publique en disant que pour sa
part il ne souhaitait pas que notre
ebadi et que notre établissement par-ci
par-là l'haltéro mais je suis ici en
tant qu'économiste la recherche dans les
banques d'investissement est
indépendante et donc c'est à ce titre je
m'exprime non pas en présentant en tant
que représentant de la deutsche bank
je ne sais pas si je parviendrai à à
percer le brouillard qui règne sur la
crise souveraine européenne en tout cas
j'essaierai de d'apporter quelques
lumières retour de trois questions c'est
assez simple croix la première c'est
peut-on identifier une quelconque
responsabilité à de la bce ou de
l'eurosystème a dans la survenance de la
crise souveraine ma réponse est
probablement oui dans une certaine
mesure mais les marges de choix pour la
banque centrale européenne était
probablement extrêmement faible deuxième
élément et y at il une contradiction
intrinsèque entre le fonctionnement de
l'union monétaire à le fonctionnement
l'eurosystème et le règlement
de la crise souveraine là ma réponse est
clairement non
et au contraire je crois que
l'eurosystème a s'est dotée des moyens
de gérer la crise ah mais gérer la crise
n'est pas et apporter une solution et
c'est ma troisième question que peut
faire la la bce pour aller au delà à de
la mise sous respirateur à des des
signatures souveraines européennes est
véritablement contribuer à une solution
on sait crise et ma réponse là dessus et
qu'elle peut beaucoup mais qu'elle ne
peut certainement pas tout et surtout
qu'elle ne peut pas tout faire seul
première question peut-on identifier
dans stabilité de leurs systèmes dans le
déclenchement de la crise oui
indirectement et dans une certaine
mesure
pierre jaillet l'a rappelé on a eu 1 1
une convergence faire l'union monétaire
qui s'est exercée essentiellement au
travers la vérification d'un certain
temps de critères a essentiellement deux
types budgétaire nous type inflation en
perdant peut-être un peu de vue d'autres
types de déséquilibre en particulier les
équilibres extérieurs
bon il est vrai et je crois que ce n'est
absolument pas contestable que lorsque
l'on s'amuse à calculer des taux
d'intérêts idéaux si vous voulez sur ce
qu'a fait la bce de 1999 on pourrait
assez facilement à conclure que la
politique monétaire menée par la bce de
1999 à peu près 2007 a essentiellement
été adaptée aux besoins des économies
dans la croissance était faible et en
particulier l'économie allemande
pour moi c'est un élément qui est
complètement incontestable à ce qui
m'amène d'ailleurs souvent devant
l'auditoire allemand puisque je
travaille pour la deutsche bank a
rappelé ces épisodes a rappelé le fait
que la politique monétaire extrêmement
accommodante de nos messieurs pendant
ces années-là a également permis à
l'allemagne
de retrouver des marges de manoeuvre à
un moment où elle mettait en place ce
qui était probablement nécessaire un
programme de réformes structurelles qui
est extrêmement coûteux à court terme en
termes de croissance de la demande
intérieure sans ce soutien à implicite
de la part la politique monétaire j'ai
bien peur que l'expérience allemande de
restauration la compétitivité poste 1995
aurait malheureusement échoué à le rend
son de ce type de politique c'est que au
même moment on n'a pas pu empêcher une
véritable surchauffe dans un certain
nombre de pays qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
périphériques à essaha ça fait aussi
partie de cette grande question de la
responsabilité des uns et des autres
pour moi il y avait quand même il y a
une difficulté a accusé les pays comme
l'espagne comme l'irlande de tous les
maux à partir du moment où les taux
d'intérêt réels auxquels il était
confronté étaient négatifs et sont
restés négatifs longtemps pendant une
crème période de croissance relativement
forte
ça ne les exonère pas de toute
responsabilité
mais ça identifie un problème dans le
fonctionnement de leur système qui sera
probablement amenée à être revu
lorsqu'on sera sortie à de la dune du du
gif delà de la crise à savoir à la
nécessaire complémentarité à deux
politiques de régulation nationales pour
éviter que des politiques monétaires
trop laxistes ou au contraire trop
restrictive se traduisent par un
comportement du crédit anormale d'un
certain nombre de pays membres à la
banque d'espagne avait essayé de
répondre à cette ce problème en mettre
en place un provisionnement 10 pro
cycliques c'est-à-dire en obligeant les
banques espagnoles à accroître leurs
efforts de provisionnement dans les
années de vaches grasses jusqu'à la
récession de 2008
cela n'a pas suffi et ça c'est une
question qui pour moi est maintenant
centrale comment peut-on enfin pour moi
la seule manière de faire fonctionner
une politique monétaire unique à dans un
cadre encore relativement hétérogènes
pour les états membres
c'est de permettre à la régulation
bancaire de jouer un rôle extrêmement
fort à dans la pays en surchauffe
a maintenant ça pas grand chose de se
focaliser sur le passé donc parlons
plutôt du présent et de l'avenir à une
question récurrente pour moi qui suis
confronté je vis au royaume uni depuis
six ans et qui fut confronté à des
investisseurs plutôt d'origine anglo
saxonne assez à cette question 1 2 la
pérennité ou de la validité de
l'expérience union monétaire et la
manière dont je réponds à cette question
est assez simple c'est de présenter
l'union humanitaire européenne comme un
système de changes fixes intelligent
alors qu'est-ce que s'il y a un teint
j'assiste change fixe intelligent c'est
à dire qu'il ya système de changes fixes
bête
allez un exemple de change fixe bête
c'est le l'étalon or a dans son
fonctionnement des années 1920-1930
je crois c'est toujours intéressant de
revenir sur cette période là parce que
malheureusement tout cas certains jours
de 2010 2011
on a pu un certain certes un certain
moment croire qu'on y était revenu
l'étalon or des années 1920 1930 ne
marche pas
non pas simplement ou non pas surtout
parce qu'il empêche les états de
dévaluer de retrouver leur compétitivité
et leur remettre ces pays sur le chemin
de croissance
il échoue parce qu'il n'y a pas de
système a construit qui permettent un
échange de liquidités entre les
différentes banques centrales nationales
si on prend l'exemple même de la crise
majeure des années 30 à savoir la
faillite d'une crise einstein en
autriche en 1931 la raison fondamentale
de cette explosion c'est le fait qu'à
l'époque à la banque de france la banque
d'angleterre
le fed n'ont pas été capables de se
mettre d'accord suffisamment rapidement
pour apporter les liquidités nécessaires
à la banque centrale autrichienne et a
réglé le problème du credit and stable
on a rigoureusement un système inverse
aujourd'hui d'ennui monétaire par le
biais de cet accès à la liquidité qui a
été rendu son amante allemand illimité
et ça on doit rendre je pense grâce à la
bce l'eurosystème dans son ensemble
pouvoir compris très très vite et dès le
début de la crise et avant la banque
d'angleterre
et même avant ça ne mesurent lalafell
pour a compris que cette question de
l'accès à l'égalité est absolument
centrale et c'était assouplissement
continuent elles à des règles à de
collatéral qui permet en fait aux
banques privées de l'ensemble à des pays
membres y compris dans les pays membres
qui souffre actuellement qui sont sous
sous sous sous l' attaque des marchés et
ce qui permet à ces déséquilibres de
lens courante de ne pas faire exploser
le système s'il n'y avait pas cet accès
illimité à la liquidité
on ne pourrait pas actuellement
continuer à financer les déséquilibres
de balance courante qui sont aujourd'hui
manifestent même s'ils se réduisent dans
la zone euro
qu'est ce qui se passe normalement
lorsque vous avez un déficit de balance
courante normalement vous avez en face à
des afflux de capitaux qui vont vous
permettre de régler votre facture
vis-à-vis du reste du monde
que se passe-t-il quand à ses capitaux
en provenance du reste du monde ne
viennent plus ce qui est très exactement
le cas du portugal dans une moindre
mesure à de l'espagne et l'italie
aujourd'hui à et bien dans un cadre
normal entre guillemets ça explose ça
explose parce que au bout d'un moment la
banque centrale nationale à neuneu ne
peut plus tirer sur ses réserves de
change
le fait que nous ayons un système de
paiement centralisé dans la zone euro
appelée target2 qui repose
essentiellement sur l'accès illimité
encore une fois à aller liquidités dans
les banques centrales est absolument et
c'est quelque chose qui est souvent peu
peut remarquer en tout cas en france est
absolument et c'est important
et si je ne me trompe certains
économistes allemands tout à fait
j'allais venir ont développé des
analyses pour montrer que le système
target n'était pas neutre et conduisait
selon eux à ce que l'allemagne en
réalité face crédit aux autres alors que
faut-il penser de cette approche fait
référence à pas raison des propos tenus
par hans werner sinn qui est le patron
de
l'ifo faut savoir cette question de
target 2 et de l'accumulation d'une
dette du reste de l'eurosystème
vis-à-vis la bundesbank est extrêmement
populaire en allemagne y compris dans la
presse
j'allais dire la plus la plus simple
bild zeitung fait régulièrement
référence à lui 2 je crois que là il ya
une erreur d'analysé entre guillemets
qui tient au fait qu' il n'y a pas vial
si son dernier target e d'accroissement
de l'exposition allemande vis-à-vis des
pays périphériques
ce qui se met en place en fait c'est une
substitution a atteint 6 heures privait
des failles entre guillemets en tout cas
qui ne veulent plus soutenir les pays
périphériques à 2 de financement de
financement bundesbank dans quelle
mesure est douloureux pour l'allemagne
ça ne l'est pas ça ne crée actuellement
absolument aucune tension sur le système
financier allemand tout dans la dans la
mesure où on ne réalise pas à vous en
laisse
le système à croître de manière
illimitée ce qui actuellement sont son
fonctionnement ce que ce que hans werner
sinn voudrais c'est que l'on mette en
place une limite à sur les financements
target 2 c'est très exactement ce qui
provoquera une explosion si en revanche
les crédits sont continue à dériver à
deux manières de manière illimitée on
peut éviter continuer à gérer cette
crise donc là dessus je crois qu'on a un
modèle qui est infiniment plus solide
qu'on ne le croit et qui organise de
manière quasiment automatique de la
solidarité financière à l'intérieur de
la zone euro troisième question est mon
c'était mon dernier point la bce via à
laleu via à l'injection de liquidités et
vite fondamentalement une explosion de
système
est-ce que ça suffit à résoudre la crise
née crise souveraine a probablement non
et ce n'est probablement pas le job
pardon de travail de l'abaisser je crois
pour
les investisseurs aujourd'hui surtout
ceux qui ne sont pas situés dans la zone
euro ont besoin d'être rassurés sur un
certain nombre d'éléments et en besoins
particuliers de rassurer sur la logique
des politiques qui sont mises en place
et force est de constater que la logique
n'a pas toujours été au rendez vous en
2011 2010 et 2011 on peut passer en
revue peut-être de deux erreurs à
première erreur sur le fsf le système de
se raidir financière de la zone euro le
temps perdu à la mise en place ce
système a été je crois absolument
castrophique c'est un système
complètement cumulatif dans lequel à des
montants relativement raisonnable s'il
avait été disponible immédiatement
aurait probablement suffi à enrayer la
crise
à partir du moment où le marché poussait
les choses
un étage supplémentaire demandée en fait
des montants encore plus important ce
qui en retour créé une pression
politique sur les états membres de plus
en plus lourde et qui donnait cette
impression à d'un système politique
européen qui courent après les
événements de marché et qui ne parvient
jamais les arrêter ça ça a été un
élément absolument absolument central et
j'y reviendrai dans ma conclusion
deuxième élément à ça peut paraître
simple mais il ne sert à rien d'attirer
l'attention des observateurs les
investisseurs sur des problèmes
lorsqu'on ne se donne pas à priori les
moyens de les régler à et là dessus on
peut parler brièvement de la question
des stress tests de l'autorité bancaire
européenne
je crois que il y avait là une bonne
intention qui était
réaliser un exercice de transparence sur
l'exposition des uns des autres à la
crise souveraine européenne ce point de
vue là c'est très bien mais à partir du
moment où on met en évidence à des à des
besoins en capital il faut avoir
immédiatement les moyens d'y faire face
et il fallait pouvoir y faire face de
manière publique
le fsf normalement sert à ça mais le fsf
au moment où les stress tests ont été
sortis n'avait de toute manière pas à
les moyens de répondre à cette à cette
question et ça c'est absolument
important je crois et je suis absolument
d'accord avec pierre jaillet que la mise
en place de la prise en pension à 3 ans
est absolument crucial actuellement et
c'est ça qui essentiellement à expliquer
le revirement des démarches et pourquoi
ça tout simplement parce que on a retiré
du système une source d'anxiété massive
qui était le risque d'une explosion en
vol système bancaire européen 2012
sachant qu'il y avait 600 milliards de
dettes bancaires qui devait arriver à
maturité en 2012 la mise en place de la
prise en pension à 36 mois c'est très
exactement le moyen de répondre à cela
cela étant il ya un deuxième étage
normalement delà de la deûle à présent
pour sur 36 mois on compte
fondamentalement même si c'est implicite
dans ce que dit la bce sur les banques
pour utiliser l'opportunité créée par la
prise en pension à 36 mois pour revenir
vers le marché souverain et financer les
états assuré temps ça ça dépend d'une
décision rationnelle des banques
et là dessus on a bien vu que la stand
d'éléments étaient pas forcément rendez
vous en espagne
il y a eu immédiatement une réaction
extrêmement forte des banques après la
présentation à 36 mois et un retour
immédiat de manière massive vers le
marché souverain expérience tout à fait
réussie en espagne en italie on n'est
probablement pas passé loin d'un échec
on n'est pas passé loin d'un échec parce
que à l'origine lorsque la prise en
pension à 36 mois a été annoncé ce que
les banques italiennes ont demandé c'est
qu'on les rassure sur leurs expositions
souveraines
on ne peut pas dans un premier temps
punis
1 les banques italiennes pour avoir une
exposition trop importante vis-à-vis
leur souverain ce qui a été le fait du
stress tests a mis en place par
l'autorité bancaire européens pour leur
demander quelques mois plus tard de bien
vouloir revenir sur le marché souverain
pour permettre au gouvernement italien
de passer un moment extrêmement
difficile en termes de liquidités et ça
on peut aussi à dire merci à la bce
parce que cet élément de doutes sur
l'efficacité de l'haltéro la prise en
pension à 36 mois pour transférer des
fonds si je puis dire vers les états a
été levé lorsque monsieur draghi s'est
exprimé pour dire qu'il n'y aurait pas
de probablement de nouveaux stress tests
en 2012 mise en place plus arrêtés par
l'autorité bancaire européenne c'était
très exactement ce que les banques
italiennes voulait entendre avant de
pouvoir les faire le marché
conclusion on aide on soutient on évite
les catastrophes
cela étant la solution pour moi la crise
souveraine
elle dépend essentiellement des états
eux-mêmes fondamentalement même si
l'haltéro à 36 mois à creysse espèce de
choc électrique dans le marché qui fait
qu'un certain nombre de gens
essentiellement aux etats-unis au
royaume-uni ont changé des vies sur la
pérennité de la zone euro c'était très
important de le faire
cela étant à la preuve est dans le
pudding pour reprendre cette expression
et annie que j'aime bien à l'italie par
exemple continuera à voir ces sprays
disait d'allemagne s'améliorer si
l'italie continue à progresser sur ce
que les marchés demandent
essentiellement ce qui n'est pas
fondamentalement réduire le déficit
aujourd'hui elle a dit à la situation
un budgétaire italienne aujourd'hui est
plutôt satisfaisante
la question fondamentale pour l'italie
c'est celle de mettre en place des
réformes structurelles qui permettront
de soutenir la croissance est de rendre
la dette publique italienne soutenable à
terme
est ce assez dépendant d'un programme
politique sur laquelle la bce évidemment
à n'a pas grand n'a par ailleurs pas
grand contrôle
dernière phrase de 2,2 conclusion est
désolé d'être aussi long que peuvent
faire la bce si tour at et là dessus
c'est quand même la question du smp qui
reste centrale six tours à tous sens que
que se passe-t-il si après un premier
effet positif de l'haltéro retombe dans
les ornières par exemple parce que la
vie politique italienne redevient un
tout petit peu compliqué où par exemple
parce que l'espagne ne parvient pas à
trouver un accord avec les régions
italiennes et à la clé région pour faire
baisser son déficit que fait on que
fait-on et là je crois que le smp et
doit quand même être l' arme de dernier
ressort
je comprends toutes les raisons qui font
que la bce n'a aucun intérêt après
annoncé une intervention du smp des
achats d'obligations massive cela étant
je crois que le marché aujourd'hui
fonctionne assure la conviction
implicite que la banque centrale
européenne fera le métier entre
guillemets si jamais les choses devaient
s'avérer un totalement totalement
toxiques qu'elles ne le disent pas me
paraît parfaitement normal plus la bce
de dire à moins les états donneront en
termes de progrès sur le réforme
merci beaucoup pour la mise en pension
et l'intérêt à de la mise en pension à
36 mois vous ne parlez que de l'italie
et de l'espagne
pourquoi vous ne faites pas le bilan à
propos de la france parce que là je fais
référence à ce que les marchés appelle
gentiment le sarko trail à qui était ce
qui a été immédiatement considérée comme
étant à la conclusion entre guillemets
de l'haltéro à 36 mois qui était que au
delà d'un soutien au refinancement
bancaire à il s'agissait aussi de
permettre ou d'inciter les banques à
financer les états en allant aux
adjudications de titres publics en 2012
et les deux états qui était très
éveillée très évidemment dans le
collimateur des marchés si je puis dire
de ce point de vue là c'est lé marché
italien des marchés espagnols
j'ajouterai en plus que sur les 600
milliards de dettes bancaires qui devait
venir à échéance en 2012
à peu près un quart concernant les
banques espagnoles seul donc play le
terreau attend six mois allait quand
même très aisément diriger vers faire
ces deux états merci j'ai tout monsieur
l'économiste en chef
voilà donc nous reviendront peut-être
sur le sarcopte web qui vous le voyez
est à la fois imaginatif et efficace
n'est ce pas alors je je je m'en doute
bien alors je me tourne vers patrick
artus et on nous parle donc d'une
facilité illimité alors est ce la
martingale qui permettra d'envisager le
dépassement de nos contradictions et ses
c est quelque chose de tout à fait
fascinant et il ya dans mon département
des conseils municipaux qui vote des
délibérations pour demander à bénéficier
de la facilité 1%
bon alors et vous allez nous dire ce
qu'il convient certainement de leur de
leur répondre mais et pour vous lancer
j'aurais tendance à dire est ce que le
bilan d'une banque centrale est par
nature illimitée est ce que c'est le
seul bilan et qu'ils puissent croître
sans qu'aucune contrainte ne s'y
applique
et puis pour le reste vous nous direz
tout ce que vous avez envie de nous dire
dans la même durée que vos prédécesseurs
si vous le voulez bien
messieurs les députés merci
de lui avoir demandé et sénateurs pardon
merci de nous avoir demandé non merci
nous avons accueilli quand je vais
effectivement mais ce président répondre
à votre question et à ce que je voulais
regarder je voudrais jouer faire trois
points dans cette dans cette brève
introduction 1 sur la gestion de la
crise les court terme c'est à dire
qu'est ce qu'on peut en penser
qu'est ce qui a été fait quelques mois
c'est triste at elle été gérée mal ou
bien
deuxième point sur ce que on peut
souhaiter que fasse une banque centrale
mais plus avec une vision de moyen terme
qui n'a pas simplement dans dans une
gestion de crise courte et troisièmement
sur le lien de cette infecte sûrs d'eux
sur le rôle de la bce avec les problèmes
structurels de la zone euro et avec
quelques questions qui me paraissent
importantes
accueilli par m paraît important de
répondre alors premièrement réaction à
la crise à court terme
je crois que nous continuons à payer
aujourd'hui une erreur majeure faite
dans la gestion de la crise depuis le
début kitty des qui est de ne pas avoir
passé un message clair sur quels pays
sont confrontés à une crise de
solvabilité et quels pays sont
confrontés à une crise de liquidité sur
gadret la doctrine du fmi
c'est devenu un sujet majeur
effectivement par le fmi des se demander
si un pays est solvable et simplement
illiquides c'est à dire pour une raison
quelconque les marchés financiers ne
veulent plus lui prêter pendant un
certain temps ou bien si un pays est en
réalité insolvables et on doit traiter
de façon complètement différente les
problèmes de solvabilité épreuve de
liquidités si un pays est simplement ils
liquident exemple la corée en 1997 le
brésil en 1998 etc
on doit effectivement mobilisés des
prêts pour le montant qu'il faut le plus
rapidement possible pour éviter que ce
pays devienne un seul va parce qu'un
pays de liquide va ses taux d'intérêt
montent et et peut devenir insolvable
par la simple réaction de ses taux
d'intérêt et si un pays est insolvable
ça ne sert à rien de lui prêter plus
parce que toute façon il peut pas
rembourser
et donc il faut adopter un autre
traitement qui consiste à identifier la
cause du problème de solvabilité
tu es à annuler une partie des dettes du
pays pour l'aider à redevenir solvables
et à vérifier que les politiques mises
en place le conduisent bien revenir
solvable quand on fait ce travail pour
la zone euro mon sentiment en regardant
les chiffres c'est qu'il ya un seul pays
qui est en réalité un seul watier la
grèce et que les autres y compris le
portugal ce qui n'est pas le sentiment
des marchés financiers aujourd'hui sont
en réalité solvables c'est un pas tout à
fait clairement le cas de l'espagne et
de l'italie et le portugal montrent des
signes très clairs d'amélioration de son
économie que vous regardiez les
exportations la productivité de
l'industrie il ya vraiment des signes
qui montrent que ce pays est en train de
s'améliorer donc je pense que le
portugal va moins mal que le consensus
des marchés mais c'est pas 2 irlandais
solvable à l'irlande s'est complètement
seul apple ireland un excédent extérieur
l'irlande a un problème d'or qui est
très différent des autres qui étaient un
problème simplement de l'absurdité de la
gestion de la bulle immobilière et de la
cité sont des banques irlandaises donc
c'est pas preuve de fond d'économie
l'irlande est complètement seul je crois
vraiment que seule la grèce est
radicalement insolvable alors quand ta
paye et illiquides
là je reprends ce qui risque a dit
gilles qui me paraît extrêmement
important donc je pars dont gilles je
vais te je vais redire ce que tu as dit
mais il faut évidemment lui prêter on
n'a pas trop envie en europe que les
prêts soit fait par le fmi parce qu un
autre cas dans la zone euro quand c'est
la hongrie ou la roumanie on laisse
faire le ferry dans la zone euro on
préfère se soit pas le fmi donc on va
faire une solution de la zone euro est
la seule solution de la zone euro à ce
moment là c'est celle assez les clans la
banque centrale européenne je reviendrai
deux minutes sur le long terme et je
crois qu'il faut redire ce qui est dit
j'étais très importante de sensations
structurelles les relais ripaud et en
particulier les pots à trois ans de la
banque centrale européenne sont des
eurobonds d'1 c'est la seule forme que
nous ayons d'euros bond puisque si bce
prête à quelqu'un qu'il rembourse pas
elle va demander aux états de bien
vouloir lui régler la facture est donc
une solidarité deux fait des états
derrière les prêts de la bce
donc les répond à trois ans sont décédés
facto moralement d euro bond à trois ans
et donc on fait effectivement la seule
chose et c'était euro bond en terme de
solidarité
du risque pris donc c'est la seule
solution pour les pays en crise de
liquidité c'est d'avoir la banque
centrale prêté avec cette solidarité
collective qui apporte le fmi donc ce
que fait la bce est extraordinairement
bien la différence entre gilles et moi
c'est mon président par contre lui veut
s'endetter le plus possible à trois ans
la bce
l'objectif étant d'ailleurs raisonnable
ce qui est de continuer à prêter aux pme
françaises
s'ils me paraît un objectif avouables de
d'un gros d'une grosse ligne
d'endettement dans les ripoux de la bce
par contre quand un pays est insolvable
on peut pas faire ça et là le traitement
de la grèce depuis le début est absurde
de dire ce pays va être traité comme
l'italie et on va lui prêter plus en
attendant qu'il puisse lui-même
rembourser rétablir sa situation c'est
juste impossible
les exportations de la grèce sont 35%
plus basse aujourd'hui qu'au début de la
crise allait l'économie grecque est en
train de disparaître et la seule chose
qu'on sait dire aux grecs et regarder ce
qui est en train de se débattre en ce
moment c'est soyez gentils mettait tout
le monde au chômage est redevenu
solvable et ce qui évidemment est
absurde donc le traitement de la grèce
est radicalement stupide pour vol d'hier
est donc il fallait dès le départ
acceptées et agressent et est insolvable
et traiter la grèce le fmi l'aurait fait
c'est à dire une réduction considérable
de sa dette
une perte pour tout le monde que ce soit
des prêteurs publics ou privés et de
l'argent qui servent à redresser
l'économie grecque la totalité de
l'argent prêté par l'europe et le fmi à
la grèce sert à rembourser les prêteurs
anciens et on en arrive au degré
d'absurdité de ceux d'hier matin où la
france et l'allemagne mais en mettre sur
pied une proposition pour que les prêts
européens la grèce soit mis dans un
fonds qui est immédiatement rendu aux
anciens prêteur doit soit être bien sûr
qui a rien qui vient alimenter
l'économie grecque au passage
donc on est dans l'absurdité totale dans
le traitement de la grèce alors pourquoi
l'at-on fait hélas jean claude trichet
remous rapportent une très lourde
responsabilité
bien sûr mais je n'ai que des pierres
qui le force ne veut pas le dire et et
qui y est on le fait parce qu'ils ont eu
peur de la contagion
andy mais si on dit que les grecs rebond
seront pas alors tout le monde va penser
pourquoi d'ailleurs les italiens
remboursera et il est en réalité la
seule solution était dès le départ de
tracer cette ligne extrêmement fermes
entre solvabilise
les liquidités sur david lean nous avons
un corps de pays insolvable et les
autres sont simplement en situation dite
difficultés transitoires
on aurait réduit considérablement le
risque de contagion on n'a jamais voulu
faire ce traitement différentiel donc
effectivement on a couru le risque de
contagion et on n'a pas voulu admettre
et grecs ne renoncerons pas un seul euro
de l'heure 400 milliards d'euros de
dette aurait réduit le risque et on
aurait beaucoup atténué me semble-t-il
le coup tu es bien sûr on en revient
coûte infinie infinitésimale par rapport
à celui qu'on a vécu en faisant en
rentrant finalement donnant le problème
au fmi dès le départ parce qu'ils ont
été une bien meilleure solution que de
le donner aux gouvernements européens ou
à la commission
voilà ce que je veux dire sur le
traitement à court terme de la crise
ensuite les risques vous posez la
question déjà prêche pas ce long terme
et avec les risques courus par la bce
sont quand même pas très élevé enfin si
la bce fait des prêts à des pays d'hôte
on ne nous voit fait l'analyse que leurs
problèmes étaient apprennent de
liquidités en réalité la bce ne peut que
gagner de l'argent en faisant ses
preuves puisque par définition les taux
d'intérêt de ces pays vont baisser ce
qui se passe donc faudra me rendre
compte qu'on n'est pas de mauvais actifs
sur le bilan de la bce quand la réserve
fédérale va acheter des abbesses
d'immobilier américain un peu bizarre
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose que
d'acheter de la dette italienne
donc je crois pas que la bce soit en
train de prendre des risques à son bilan
à condition bien sûr de ne prêter à
directement copé illiquides alors juste
un mot maintenant sur sur les banques il
est disons la pondération relative du
smp certes des achats directs de la bce
duel terreau je crois que là on à
nouveau par le choix draghi est
quelqu'un de très pragmatique faire un
mp plus gros c'était
se confrontaient que le parlement
allemand faire faire le travail par les
banques
finalement c'est une façon habile de ne
pas se confronter d'autres pas en
conflit que le parlement allemand et une
fine et ça revient à peu près au même
bien sûr les banques françaises n'auront
aucune raison de le faire aujourd'hui
parce que la france se finance en
dessous de 3% donc à aucun besoin que
les banques aident au financement de la
france mais que les banques italiennes
ou espagnoles le fasse quelque chose ou
belges quelque chose qui me choque
absolument pas mais il faut se rendre
compte que c'est une manière détournée
de faire faire le financement par la bce
attend le lte héros ne sert pas qu'à ça
en france le lt héros est en train
d'éviter un rationnement du crédit des
pme parce qu'il est quand même quelque
chose qui est extrêmement positif alors
deuxième tout et je vais plus vite sur
le long terme
g j'ai deux problèmes avec le projet de
traité européen que je voudrais
mentionner avec vous et un problème avec
les statuts de la bce première problème
avec le projet de traité en fin de droit
je fais 1 et après faire ça je ne crois
pas du tout le ffs m soit le prêteur en
dernier ressort le firewall comme disent
les anglais légitime
il faut se rappeler que c'est un
émetteur obligataire et donc les débats
pour savoir s'il doit pouvoir avoir
disposé de 500 de 750 aux 2000 milliards
d'euros sur des débats totalement
surréaliste pour l'instant le ffa
ennemis 19 milliards dont 6 milliards à
court terme avec de grandes difficultés
un programme d'émission pour l'instant
zéro on n'a pas été annoncée et de toute
façon est totalement incapable d'émettre
ces montants là sur le marché
obligataire donc il faut quand même se
rendre compte que le prêteur en dernier
ressort utilise la création monétaire si
besoin de beaucoup d'argent très vite
pouvait pas aller sur le marché
obligataire c'est ce quelque chose me
paraît de bon sens si l'italie par
malheur tomber dans une crise
d'insolvabilité et qu'ils fassent
débloquer beaucoup d'argent pour
l'italie
à ce moment là les marchés obligataires
sont fermées par construction parce que
ce serait une crise grave et un émetteur
obligataire n'a aucune chance de pouvoir
émettre le moindre euro financement pour
l'italie dit à nos clients américains
c'est dire l'italie va mal et donc elle
va garantir le fond qui va lever de
l'argent pour la financer ceci ne peut
pas marcher
donc il va quand même falloir comprendre
qu'il faut
que le ffs m soit 7 viennent la bce soit
et un accès au financement monétaire
d'un bessieux comme le fmi un accès au
financement monétaire des banques
centrales sinon ça ne marchera pas et
nous n'avons pas de firewall ma
conviction est que nous aurons d'autres
crises de liquidités tant qu'il y aura
pas d'euro bond
parce qu'on a dit cet émetteur souverain
dans la même monnaie ce qui n'existe
nulle part ailleurs
ce que je raconte un meilleur américain
s'est imaginé que les 50 états des états
unis qui épate trésor des états unis
les 50 états doivent se financé
indépendamment sur les marchés combien
ne pourrait pas la réponse de
l'américain général cette question c'est
une trentaine un don qu'il y aurait 20
états qui réussirait à se financer sur
les marchés
donc évidemment avec 10 m et émetteurs
souverains vous avez un risque continue
elle de crise de liquidités si on va
résoudre celle ci et puis dans trois ans
ça sera peut-être la belgique ou la
france on n'en sait rien et donc il
faudra un prêteur en dernier ressort il
faudra qu'ils puissent utiliser la
création monétaire donc le projet de
traité ne va pas me semble ne va pas du
tout sur ce point deuxième question qui
est alors bien sûr il faut régler leur
pierre l'a dit et je le redis mais tout
le monde le sait et pierre benoit raison
il faut il bien évidemment régler
prennent d'aléas de moralité c'est qu'on
peut pas être prêté en dernière
souverain sous prêteur en dernier
ressort aux emprunteurs souverains sans
conditions mais ça c'est clair deuxième
problème que j'ai avec le long terme
c'est ce que doit faire la lune banque
centrale je pense qu'une banque centrale
doit intervenir sur les marchés
stratégiques d'actifs financiers pour en
maintenir le bon fonctionnement
ce que les banques centrales refusant
général de faire et donc s'agit pas de
le faire uniquement localement
transitoirement je pense que c'est celle
là c'est la celulle ces métiers normal
des banques centrales de faire en sorte
qu'ils aient pas de crise de liquidités
sur des marchés financements
stratégiques de l'économie ou des
banques est donc une banque centrale
doit tout moment être capable soit
d'empêcher quai des bulles d'ailleurs
sur ces marchés ce qu'elles sont pas
faits vous le rappeliez tout à l'heure
soit qu'elle est vite que ses marchés se
ferme de façon systématique si je crois
que c'est c'est le métier des banques
centrales des acheteurs ou vendeurs
d'actes de toutes sortes d'actifs
financiers sur les marchés et pas
simplement de contrôler le compartiment
très courts du marché obligataire
voilà donc c'est les banques centrales
même pas du tout cette idée pour toutes
sortes de raisons qu'on connaît
je vois pas comment on assure la
stabilité financière si on laisse se
fermer les marchés financiers
périodiquement donc ça donnerait un rôle
radicalement différent banque centrale
qui serait un rôle de stabilité
financière alors pas sur n'importe quel
marché d'actif mais sur ceux qui ont un
rôle clé dans le financement des banques
et d'économie alors dernier point sur
l'épreuve structurelles liées de la zone
euro et de questions qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui ce que nous faisons
aujourd'hui il faut se rendre compte que
ça ne peut pas être une solution de long
terme et je crois que pierre et gilles
l'ont déjà dit on est en train de sortir
de la crise de liquidités
d'une part la renationalisation de
l'épargné en gros aujourd'hui les
assureurs et les banquiers français ne
prêtent qu'à la france c'est sur les
banques italiennes prêtes qu'à l'italie
et les banques et assureurs français
vendent tout ce qu'ils auront en italie
en espagne au portugal et achète pas
d'albane qu'est ce que ça rapporte pas
assez donc qu'ils achètent que de la
france c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que le
mystère du taux de financement de l'état
français serait glace et que les
assureurs français peuvent pas acheter
de l'allemagne parce que ça rapporte pas
assez sinon on aurait déjà une crise
financière en france mais voilà mais on
peut pas vivre enfin ça c'est pas ça
peut pas être une situation de long
terme dans la zone euro que l'épargné ne
finance que les besoins en financement
domestique de chacun des pays ce qui est
en train de se produire en ce moment
c'est aussi absurde en allemagne sur les
allemands se force à ne prêter qu'aux
allemands et le seul emprunteur en
allemagne c'est l'étalement qui
d'ailleurs en prennent pratiquement plus
rien donc on est en train de fabriquer
une gigantesque bulle sur le marché
obligataire allemand parce que les
allemands refusent de prêter aux autres
et donc ce qui nous sort de la crise
aujourd'hui évidemment est totalement
absurde dans le long terme et conduit à
quelque chose qu'on se demande pourquoi
on a leur aussi d'ailleurs les pagnes
doit rester à l'intérieur des frontières
nationales dans chacun des pays
deuxième point ce que nous faisons
aujourd'hui est aussi en train de tuer
la croissance potentielle de la zone
euro à long terme
on a à la fois une très forte réduction
des investissements des entreprises
puisque les entreprises ne veulent plus
endettés et une très forte réduction des
investissements publics puisque les
états veulent faire disparaître leurs
déficits et que c'est plus facile de
tuer les investissements publics
les autres dépenses des états si vous
regardez ce qu'ont fait les suédois en
92 qui se sent quand même pas mal tiré
au moment où ils ont réduit de 20 points
de yb leurs dépenses publiques en sept
ou huit ans par rapport au pire ils ont
doublé les dépenses publiques de
recherche développement dans ce qui est
quand même assez intéressant à voir
malheureusement les pays de la zone euro
font systématiquement l' inverse
aujourd'hui la partie des dépenses
publiques qui baisse le plus dans tout
les pires difficultés c'est les
investissements publics et le taux
d'investissement public de la zone euro
a baissé de 20% par rapport à cesson
d'avant crise donc nous sommes en train
de mettre en place une baisse de la
croissance de long terme de la zone pour
sortir des déficits à court terme ce qui
est aussi extrêmement dangereux et la
dernière question que je voudrais poser
ces questions suivantes qui doit à long
terme financer les états aujourd'hui
c'est la bce et les banques ce qui est
quand même extrêmement qui est
normalement pas leur métier à nouveau ça
doit être perçue juste comme une
situation de crise pour la bestiole est
à l'heure et pour les banques mais c'est
pas le métier des banquiers de financer
les états alors malheureusement le
régulateur valois l'a pas compris ou non
plus puisque vous savez que la
régulation des banques maintenant à
créer un ratio de liquidité qui en
réalité force les banques à financer les
états c'est vraiment pas le métier des
banques de financer les états sauf
aujourd'hui on est ravi que les banques
italiennes ou espagnoles le fasse et
vous voulez vous avez le modèle du japon
où le déficit public du japon depuis 20
ans et financés par les banques
japonaises avec la conséquence que
depuis vingt ans les entreprises
japonaises n'ont pas pu obtenir de
crédit bancaire qui femmes pas une très
bonne idée donc ça ne peut pas être le
modèle de long terme le modèle de long
terme c'est un modèle où les états sont
financés par des investisseurs à long
terme sur des caisses de retraite des
fonds de pension des assureurs-vie x
trail pas par les banques donc il
faudrait pas et voilà donc troisième
raison pour laquelle ce qui est je
comptais là-dessus ce qui nous sauve
finalement de la crise aujourd'hui ce
sont trois caractéristiques très
indésirable à long terme
1 c'est la création monétaire par la bce
mais à nouveau c'est une pratique de
crise a peut pas qu'une pratique de long
terme c'est l'intervention des banques
massifs dans le financement des états
dans les pays en difficulté et c'est la
baisse très forte des tours
d'investissements pour réduire les
besoins de financement des pays
je vais redire pour en conclusion ce
qu'a dit gilles en réalité ce que nous
avons assez une crise pas de l'été
public mais c'est une crise de déficit
extérieur ce qui s'est passé en europe
c'est que les pays du nord ne veulent
plus prêter aux pays du sud et donc
transitoirement on peut organiser une
astuce qui s'appelle la bce pour que les
allemands se rendent pas entièrement
compte qu'en réalité on prend encore
leur épargne pour le vol à prêter aux
pays du sud en mettant au milieu le
bilan de la bce
c'est sûr on parlait tous les trois au
début mais mais mais mais mais
intrinsèquement ce qui est en train de
se passer c'est l'apparition d'une
énorme contrainte extérieure pour tous
les pays qui ne veut plus avoir de
déficit extérieur quand vous pouvez plus
avoir de déficit extérieur bas il n'ya
qu'une seule solution à nouveau c'est
d'investir mois de renationaliser votre
épargne et de faire disparaître les
déficits publics et mais c'est hot hot
extraordinairement indésirables on ne
rendra à nouveau de tuer la croissance
potentielle de la zone euro si on ne
permet plus que les tarn circulent
librement à l'intérieur de la zone euro
soit parce que les allemands veulent
plus prêter swaps et que les autres sont
contraints à l équilibre extérieur à
tout moment parce que les parts ne
circulent plus donc faut se rendre
compte que c'est cette bizarrerie les
choses vont continuer à s'améliorer pour
des raisons qui sont horribles dans
leurs conséquences de long terme
donc voilà pourquoi je voulais terminer
voilà pour cette table ronde consacrée à
l'avenir de la zone euro pour la revoir
notre site internet publicsenat.fr
prochain rendez vous avec à les travaux
parlementaires c'est cet après midi à
15h très belle journée à tous